It's A Gentleman's Relish oh okay fish  it has a picture of a fish on it  delicious on hot toast cold  this is going to be pretty rough this is  salted anchovies  I'm really leaning on really just I  don't need to taste that in my life I  don't think  let's open it and see what the if it was  something like  there that I would definitely eat it  like a little travel size portion of  Nutella yeah you could just stick in  your pocket right but instead they go  okay  to appreciate the fine flavor of this  relationship should be used very  sparingly what does that mean like not a  lot  that is not going into my body this  morning  like  that is gross can you see that